une production du studio sf mais amenés
au sans filtre le broadcast on parle de
ce qu'on veut nous inviter la cites jeu
perche canton avec moi double entre
cette semaine le sans filtre et présenté
par caisse me kiss me font des caisses à
téléphone cellulaire de haut de gamme
pis pour la collaboration on est ultra
ai dit si tu montes qui est un des trois
grues rouillées on a fait des caisses
sans filtre podcast il y avait beaucoup
de monde qui demandait de la marge
maintenant on a de la marge donc il va
avoir les caisses sans filtres
disponibles sur le site de 15 me kiss me
en fait c'est un projet qui était fondée
suite à un projet universitaire en fait
en 2016 par 2 go dans le sous-sol de la
mère d'un des gars puis maintenant s'est
rendu à 16 employés
c'est vraiment là bon j'ai rencontré
william qui est cofondateur de qui est
semi puisse un gars super cool trippeux
de podcasts et puis il ya décidé de
faire ce projet là pour nous en fait
avec le sans filtre donc vous allez
pouvoir vous procurer un étui comme ceux
d'un lien dans la description en fait
puis si vous voulez aussi vous acheter
un qu'est ce que ce soit le sans fil ou
à une autre caisse vous pouvez utiliser
pardon le code promo sans filtre 20 en
un mot avec le vin été créés en chiffres
pour 20% de rabais savez disponible
pendant un mois fait que si vous voulez
pouvoir flasher mettons à de métro comme
une jarre de poignées de main secrète en
amateur du sans-fil podcasts les mardis
matin quatre peaux de castor vous
écoutez subtilement votre podcast vote
sel puis vous montrer comme celle ci
pour garder du monde dans les yeux en
leur montrant votre caisse sans fait de
podcasts c'est vraiment super cool une
moche et que je suis très fier heures en
fait c'est en nettement plus soyons plus
sérieux plus je trouve ça très cool
qu'on est maintenant quelque chose à
l'effigié du podcast que vous allez
pouvoir vous procurer pour faire partie
juste grossir le la communauté s'en fait
pas de piège content d'avoir ma face sur
un 15 2
de forme je peux me regarder dans les
yeux que jamais j'ai appelé mon père
pensait que j'allais faire de ma vie ma
façon fait qu'écouter toutes les
informations vont être dans la
description de ce podcast y encourager
qasmi qui nous encourage les autres fait
que enfin infos sur cros perles vous
avez des baux étui pour votre téléphone
le podcast est aussi commandité par
terriens terriens vous déconnez ses
bureaux de comptables 25 ans
d'expérience dans le domaine petites à
moyennes entreprises de 1 à 100 employés
il faut du particulier si je porte un
coup au dessus ouais ouais
puis sow ce parfum deux autres ayant
lyon peut en fait nous ont vraiment
aidés que nous finançons est allé les
voir faire faire avec eux autres sont
super cools sont vraiment professionnel
mais dans un cadre humain facture va
avoir pour ne pas vous faire chier en
fête avec tout ce qui est proprement par
tous qui finance tout ce qui importe où
ce qui rapporte des taxes tous qui tenue
de livres taille un terrien les livres
sont ce parfum peas sont parfaits ouais
en fait si vous utilisez aussi le code
sans filtre c'est le cas du secret si
vous leur dites que vous avez entendu
parler de leur bureau avec sans filtre
c'est 50 % de rabais sur votre première
année fiscale fait que c'est quand même
très considérable puis nous autres nous
permet de mettre notre temps dans les
podcasts dans le studio puis à place de
s'occuper de la fiscalité
merci à nos commanditaires oui sinon
aujourd'hui on a reçu pour ni eau ni
pour ni une fille une artiste en art
visuel principalement une des plus je
les ai connus talentueuse est vraiment a
fait du port toujours un coin qui avait
commencé en faisant des preuves dans des
toiles puis maintenant en fait à
fillinges a fait des t-shirts avant tout
son sens son stock en ligne il faut
aussi beaucoup de pochettes d'album
vraiment à saluer c'est un peu la haine
du québec
karam a carrément puis
une fille qu'une personnalité vraiment
ivre je connaissais pas sa personnalité
ferait son travail par des disciples et
drôle et pétillante et genre déborde
d'énergie et si c'était vrai la
conversation du fils ou pas créative du
fol espoir intéressante puisse perdre s
voilà superbe et le tuc arrange
ouais ouais sinon on a notre sans filtre
vip qui est un podcast exclusif à nos
membres
petrone on y reçoit à chaque semaine des
gens de tous les milieux qui sont moins
connus du public mais qui sont tout à
fait intéressant cette erreur a reçu un
gars que tu connais c'est bien d'en
perdre tout si kiki qui gravitent dans
ma famille qui est inquiétant un
comédien qui te remettre en scène
scénographe qui évolue dans le milieu du
théâtre on va parler vraiment
principalement de cette une valeur du
théâtre puis de son parcours à lui lui
ai fait part enfin vraiment en reste
beaucoup du circuit qui a été fait
beaucoup travailler qui est robert
lepage - fait qu'on n'a pas de lecture
par une bonne c'est super intéressant
ouais vraiment donc si vous voulez aller
voir ces conversations là le lien vers
notre pétrole et dans la description
l'essonne en faire le plus possible des
conversations comme le sans filtre mais
avec des gens moins connus du public
donc aller checker ça sinon merci à vous
nous écoutez laisser des commentaires
les symptômes the writing sait écouter
en audio ça fait son bout de chemin
on continue à croître la grande famille
du sans-fil podcast ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir de voir que vous
êtes là avec nous à chaque semaine parce
que pas de vous pas de nous fait que
nous nous on existe encore le poids car
si tu existes - pas grand' fait que
merci puis sans plus attendre
on vous laisse avec cette extrêmement
belle conversation avec pony pony run
run
[Musique]
ces partis salut ça va vous avez gabriel
peu fournis abriel est ce que l'on
appelle plus dans les dernières années
plus de gens m'appellent pour nous une
source à et confortera confortant mais
ok armani jeffrey garder un doute puis
ça finit
le truc le plus au monde pendant très
longtemps j'ai juste vu c'est un peu
comme un nom de code personnel s'est
passé oui comme mais je les accepte et
puis je comprends que dans ceux des
nouveaux amis dans vie puis ils
connaissaient peut-être pas dans le
temps que tu comprends ce genre tu étais
juste en train de ce carnet de dessins
chez comme ils t'ont connu comme pour
nip tuck savait déjà tout écrivain qui
comprend taper le même et comme un qte
surnommé au début c'est comme grand font
pas les fictions avec la villa témoin
comme un temps quitte à cenon le 2012 je
me souviens de choix conscience chez
nous j'ai juste réalisé qu'il y des
inconscients qui va arriver avant le
choix conscient non mais en fait chez
moi puis je faisais tellement d'affaires
comme créative de posture de ci dessous
de primes qui touchait comme acquis 6
diffusé en lieu de place était de ma
personnalité mes hommes chez qui ça
c'était pas il faut quelque chose pour
comme regrouper tout ça comme je joue de
neige en espèces de noms comme parce que
il y avait juste trop de différentes
avenues
puis le jeu trouve éponyme suisse au
début il y avait des points entre les
lettres que c'est un acronyme est ce
qu'on veut savoir pourquoi
ben oui commence une phrase comme pau et
c'est que moi je trouvais jolie qui
était très symbolique à ce moment là où
j'ai voulu trouver sur internet
la troupe est en fait un simple et à la
basse et comme point one news l'yonne
parce que c'est une période de ma vie où
je sortais d'une longue relation très
tumultueuse moutons j'avais des trous
alimente à ce moment le jeu des
dépendances plein de shit qui marchait
pas pigé je voyais le fait de comme le
schéma job et commencer à faire de leur
temps plein comme vraiment de nouvelles
plantes nouvelles pages une belle
opportunité m donc d'où vient comme le
new york
c'est donc peu de chance le wave
championne espèce de contradiction c'est
un truc en mode c'est comme pauvre toi
mais comme en même temps que c'était une
nouvelle motion comme peu dès que tu
décides de comme passer une nouvelle
étape dans ta vie tes nouvelles
c'est comme la nouvelle étape symbolique
de cette façon là puis et puis et puis
oui donc c'est comme très signifiants
pour moi mais simplement mais je trouve
ça je trouve ça fait vraiment on dirait
on dirait que ça solidifie
ton oeuvre dans son ensemble si on
dirait que c'est comme un peu une espèce
de je sais pas comment m'exprimer mais
admettons qu'il est laid
les artistes que tu connais l'été qu'ils
ont fait dans tous les tous les domaines
artistiques qui ont comme un non assumée
et fait ouais ouais mais bon c'était ton
ami steve jobs sayah tour serait venue
de voix qui serait comme marchisio qui
est jean lachaud y pratique ne le dit
combien on le trouvait à portée comme
non non c'est devenu quelque chose
waouh le téléthon c'est un jeu c'est
vrai que ça légitimise le tout les trucs
le tipi c'est sûr je pense qu'on en a
déjà parlé c'est lahoud qui disait à
tout le monde en parle comme d'un kayak
quelqu'un qui a un nom c'est trop en
pointe trop réfléchi c'est douteux bah
ça veut dire ça peut passer longtemps
par zakaria ses sticks et or no a 14 ans
le choix de la semaine est il relancé
car hiace seul mais séverine c'est vrai
qu'il ya deux semaines c'est tellement
vrai répit pendant toute cette lignée
l'aude comme même dit voilà les
compagnies gens copient 2010 n'entend
que toutes les compagnies magasin ça
fait quelque chose 2002 d'abord parce
qu'on est proche de l'an 2000 camions
comme papa c'est quand même en admettant
qu'on traverse leur 2 mai mais
clairement je pense que m
après ça s'est senti comme panier avec
c'est juste un peu comme mais sa bio
comme des étapes je trouve
puis amendé peut-être s'appelle douteux
mais quand cela vient peut-être comme
plus au di bello
c'est comme béton bois sécheresse jamais
piqué son sujet c'est vrai que quand sur
le nom de certaines à tavannes et c'est
l'oubli tes analyses comme samassa s'il
a lancé sa personne l'oeuvre avec le nom
qui soit
mais qu'est ce que tu fais un prince
tabacstop un nom de merde comme au début
quand tu apprends mais c'est ça c'est
parce que ça vienne d'un contexte comme
ceux comme qu'au mondial et 2000 ça
vient d'un côté scop temporellement
socialiste comme pisi qui a pris ce qui
passe est hésitant et tout comme francis
a pu apprécier le nonce ça devient
vraiment justin façon reconnaître ceux
et celles qui ont une espèce de
connotations dans l'imaginaire tout le
monde sait ça mais je dois plus entre
autres kieren la crise etc ceux qui ont
forgé leur nom soit quatre fois mais
c'est je comprends pas ce que je
comprends pas ce que clame un ton
premier nom propre comme marraine du
cnpac son nom avant c'était
weezy lave jump et bluesy stack genre
leucémie a fait beau ici parce qu'il
était vraiment attaquer la b2
bon bah ouais ouais y'a comme un bouton
qui bataillent artecom habillé comme sa
pochette
bah ouais bah c'est pour l'installation
oui je sais ça fait craindre à parler de
toutes sortes une énorme annuler la
l'année qui vient de passer le sait
comme une année sur deux explosions là
pour toi l'année passée cette année
c'est impressionnant non mais c'est
juste moi j'ai l'impression peut-être
que c'est juste parce que parce
qu'internet parlait plus de toi cette
année la colle avec élisabeth fouilloux
cinéma avec peut-être que c'est à cause
de ça mais moi j'ai l'impression que la
dernière année j'ai passé deux avoir
entendu pony quelquefois comme tout le
monde que ronnie est sur toutes les
années mais moi j'ai l'impression
mettons que maintenant au québec si tu
es un jeune en mode schepp à 30,50 impie
tu veux avoir fait refaire du write web
pour wade veut que tu fais tes la
première personne qui me viendra un
temps j'ai l'impression que c'est bon
t'es malade tu es comme mike d'attention
à la demande c'est sûr que moi j'en dis
c'est sûr que je m'entoure de comme mes
amis puissent effectuer comme je suis un
peu dans une bulle c'est sont comme des
pantins qui comme toi tu danses on vit
tout dans une espèce de bulle puis après
c'est vrai mais ok ce parce que ce soit
et je pense que j'ai réellement grande
déconnection avec la technologie
de fait c'est sûr que c'était comme plus
en symbiose avec comme instagram sécher
dans une pique était plus puis que tu
prends comme les commentaires comme tu
penses vraiment au fait que c'est des
humains
puis tout ce que j'y pense mais juste
assez pour sentir comme le respect et
l'amour comme envers ces gens là comme
ce jeu sans méchants peau mais ça je
pense un problème commun sans peau comme
l'âme
moi je ressens pas d'amour à moulins
d'or non mais comme qui me au travers un
écran
ouais pauvres et ne pas de gratification
part d'un nombre de clichés c'est qu'au
nom ferait un peu mais comme j'ai c'est
jean puy du fou je suis comme je sais
vraiment de comme faut que ce soit fait
et aussi tout comme des gens qui
apportent si c'est vraiment un message
vraiment touchant dans l'es10 enjoy
aucun j'ai vu cette rue maintenant comme
cette semaine c'est arrivé sérieusement
ça m'a ému énormément mais parce que
c'est comme une échelle de un job c'est
vraiment un message dessin puis même le
mais c'est comme ça on tapote avoua
figure comme une déconnexion mais comme
2-1 gens comme privés de même je sens
plus mais quand c'est juste comme un
grand chiffre 1 million de commentaires
non mais je sais pas si fort que moi je
sens vraiment des connexions donc comme
l'aperçu que je pense littéralement
jamais jean a recommandé comme comment
je suis perçu dans le monde comme ça
militairement jamais arrivé comme
notions comme le géant parle depuis ce
faux kenneth r ça parce que clamant je
pense pas à ces changements
des fois je me fais dire des trucs ça me
rend tellement comme mme allard est dans
un contexte peu de discussions puisque
le choc la focus et comme trop sombre où
allez-vous fétiche ceux-ci quasiment au
pied
je pense que c'est vraiment intéressant
pour moi ça qu'on s'est plus jamais faut
savoir comment vous est intéressant
pareil parce que tu es l'internet ça a
été le lieu où est ce que pour nice
était bon pour toi le site internet
sauf que tout sympa tout su l'utiliser
comme outil mais tu te sens pas investi
personnellement sur internet et je suis
comme dit syrie pour de vrai je suis
comme une contradiction absolue ces
pauvres est une des raisons pour
lesquelles dernière manche comme dans un
magnifique d'otages même du genre
comment je fais pour comme vive
je pense beaucoup à la gratitude
c'est en siégeant beaucoup au concept la
gratitude
puis j'ai réalisé que que je t'ai pas en
contact comme constant avec la gratitude
j'essaie de comprendre pourquoi pied
pourquoi je fais des petits trucs depuis
quelques temps comme je me réveille le
matin je pense à comme trois choses
attentivement appris que je suis
reconnaissante et des titres que noël
qui me qui essaient de me connecter
vraiment c'est pour que ces personnes y
sommes au contraire comme unitairement
versant plus sensibles à vue belle trop
empathie pour comme vivre dans le vrai
monde de même que mais c'est quelque
chose que tout le monde bénéficierait en
forme je dois juste prendre le temps de
faire qui est elle en fait à la faute à
la fin oui
josh je pense pas la fin de ma réflexion
mais je pense qu'un gros choc de ce qui
apparaît que le fait que mon métier
tellement liés à la technologie est
tellement dépendre les interactions que
j'ai les échos que j'ai par rapport à
mon métier sont tellement toujours
derrière un écran que yo comme un cheat
par rapport à comme la gratification de
ce que je fais comme j'arrive comme
difficilement la recevoir parce que
c'est comme dit dispose d'un écran d'une
lame anti-poux pour toute la main pour
des différentes mais je sais pour moi
c'est comme des chiffres vraiment des
mesures ultra ultra moderne team mais
comme deux cantons mais this is tille
comme une suite de connexion que ce
qu'est née après que moi j'habite dans
un quartier où comme une personne avec
lui je crois j'ai même personne genre
maintenant un mois je déménage dans un
quartier comme très populaire puis comme
genre d'art aux membres il ajuste les
fois que j'allais comme visiter mon
appartement à l'évangile le ceja je
croise comme yoplait ne sera pas tout et
la finale à l'appui comme oh my god
comme acquis peut-être le fait que j'ai
habité paquin dans un texte rien ça ça
contribue également comme
grosse réflexion mais à la base je pense
que parce que pour ma part oui une
espèce de huy des connexions technologie
c'est pas que je peux great wall et
chris noth mégevand reid mettons dans un
monde idéal gens une fois par mois et
dans une salle pleine de monde que je
n'ai plus eu comme les retards accusés
par exemple éduqué mais jusqu'à prévoir
un minimum de contact il m avait dit
quand ça arrivera relève que les gens
font et je te reconnais je pense que tu
fais ce sacrement dans les eaux ci ou
ceux ci se saouler une halte en oui
comme fumer non léger un prix h 50
merci j'ai passé par plusieurs phases
que la dernière phase avant la phase ii
comme être capable d'être comme merci
quand même récente merci et c'est tout
quel oiseau mais comme avance déjà
j'étais tellement mal à l'aise avec le
fait que quelqu'un puisse me regarder
comme d'une manière que me mettre comme
sur un piédestal
j'étais jusque dans ma tête j'étais
comme acquis je me vois pas ma chance
mais aussi naïf que se fixe je voulais
justement comme est constamment et
consciemment faire comprendre à la
personne comme doute on y est on est
égal voire qu'inégal fait le
volontairement gens je me rabaisser je
peux commander comme j'essayais d'avoir
comme co nous c'est pourquoi la personne
arabes commencent à parler comme je sais
pas juste vraiment speed le son jusqu'à
temps que je voyais comme sérieusement
jeter tel voyage
en femme ah non c'est non mais t'es
vraiment un homme comme jean bessis
jusqu'à temps que je vois dans les yeux
de la personne comme tranquillement son
pic du passé de 2 comme en haut à embout
complètement finalement ça ne marche pas
les plans des comme égal parce que j'ai
croisé pony extrêmes comme pas
constructif mais maintenant j'apprends
de plus en plus pied a jusqu'à est dans
la gratitude clamant c'est vraiment le
thème comme principal bien soin de jeu
c'est top
ok essaye de pau avoir des mécanismes et
c'est vraiment comme un chiffre comme
attitude chers comme le ton et une fille
cap si paul lecoq c'est pas comme si
j'avais comme facteur de confiance et
tout mais le ton une fille avec un
doudou une fille avec une fille portant
orientation déjà que qui est juste comme
piliers comme à québec pied comme époux
choses comme ça la transperce pop sags
mon petit et jusqu'à n'ont qu'à des flec
comme et non suivre en poussines est ce
que tu penses plus ce genre de drames
humains mais par rapport aux trucs la
technologie la déconnexion vous le vivez
page vous aussi comme vous vous êtes
comme en harmonie ex vous dans ce sens
comme pommeau de douche je transmets
plus en mode jean tu ton cerveau est
capable d'être ce chiffre les gars comme
tant d'humains ayant tous ceux qui pense
constamment chez moi je pense qu'ils
aient moi je les fait un peu dans fait
je pense que la façon que ça m'est
arrivé à moi ça m'est arrivé dans le
sens contraire de toi au sens où ce que
toi tu faisais des chutes way le saas
est transféré vers une plateforme moi
c'était je suis est devenu du jour au
lendemain sur une plateforme web pourra
lire des trucs que j'avais pas fais tu
sais je veux dire des trucs et j'avais
fait mais des trucs propos c'est pour
quelque chose qui me
c'est exact club - mon raisonnement est
un peu dans le sens contraire de me dire
je vais je vis pas très bien avec ça
mais là je vais juste essayer de me
retirer pour faire des trucs qui
éventuellement pourront peut-être me
rendre là mais par un autre chemin et
libérale plus confortable puis mettons
dans ton cas toi moi je trouve ça
complètement honoraires puis moi ça
m'impressionne beaucoup
quelqu'un qui fait juste ses propres
affaires en 2010 900 sans vous comptez
sur la réception du public tipi que ses
propres affaires sont tellement great
qui font que tu accèdes un niveau de
reconnaissance web
mais le niveau de reconnaissance web
pour moi c'est juste une c'est juste ça
devrait être juste une façon de
quantifier commenté truc pas sur le web
fonctionne ou sur le web mais tes trucs
pas sur les réseaux sociaux nous
exprimer c'est super cool que toi dis ce
que tu fasses cc tons or ces pilotes est
connu pour ton art peace est un art qui
fait que tu es connu sur instagram c'est
pas pour n'importe quelle autre raison
puis une fois pour dire que ça fait
plaisir
puis je pense que le danger c'est qu à
emmener sur les réseaux sociaux ça
devient comme une masse monolithique
c'est ce qu'on sait c'est plus des
personnes c'est juste un chiffre puisse
à ces problématiques parce que si la
valeur est établie selon le chief et là
ça vaut rien puis pisser site off c'est
cette offre en crise surtout quand on
compare les chiffres mais toi c'est quoi
130 maîtresse agrémenter ses duels à
concevoir investi 130 en watson
conservons comprends pas ce que je me
donne tout le temps c
cent mille camp gatinois avaient
fusionné
j'avais cent mille points il y avait
5000 jetons
je pense à beaucoup je pense à georges
zuka temps qu'est ce que ça signifie
100000 jours-ci est annoncée pour dans
six villages de socom 4
do you come back end en 60 kg jean macé
comme un qui sait si j'en étais condensé
qui se pressent que la haye ces femmes
d'âge il faut déjà très aisé le pouvoir
que tout c'est oui oui mais en même
temps c'est justement de dire pouvoir
saluer une connotation qui comme ça peut
être ça se passe ça peut être ça peut
partir dans tout les sens et puis m
dans tous les cas moi ma robe ma
relation avec ça c'est que je veux je
veux que ça devienne je veux que ça
devienne du monde qui me suivent pour ce
que je fais énormément qui me suivent
pour me souhaiter que c'est comme la
venue ce pays pauvre et j'y passais ya
justement mais il me fallait faire comme
une entrevue
c'est un bon moment avec fred about the
fuck pour nier fait un gilet face à face
avec courage
tellement comme pour le faire ce serait
comme occupation deux parce que en fait
mon estime on écoutait son jardin ça
parce qu'on avait des vies justement
comme extra stressante et on s'entend
pour vrai c'est le fun à regarder de
connaître la personne à l'émission ce
déclin car tu connais quelqu'un qui est
plus tendu mais en ces mois maintenant
première année bien son meilleur ami et
j'écoute ces outils crissement
j'investis nationale je vivais tout le
comité loup est issu des tentes des
tentes les extraits toutefois que je
peux avoir ton comique de l'année
d'après croyait away
ph j aurais pas non plus os et c'est ce
qu'ils achetaient le péage tape au civil
plein come stay d'années parce que
c'était pas ça le plein les bras tant
d'amour semaine bleue s'est jamais seul
plein on s'attend à ce que les gens vont
là puis tout le monde ya moi je vais
trouver l'amour mettez ça dans une
émission de caméras partout de choix
cette personne si je sais pas le
meilleur set up pour ton badin mots
pareils c'est depuis ma peau fac en tout
cas mais quand ça arrive pour vrai qu'il
ya un site qui marche
regardez sa poursuite racheté un peu
mais non mais on y rythmant devenu comme
ce que je réalise et puis la manière
qu'ils ont voulu y voit des puisque
j'avais jamais que tu es sotoba sont
deux pistes et que la membrane des pour
plus plat rat comme déjà exactement
parce que dans le temps j'ai plus à
présenter comme j'étais pâte d'amande
avec la vague
dans le temps de 2 comme quasiment
sauvegarde comme pour te moquer j'ai
commencé par rapport à l'action comme si
son apparence je suis tellement mal pour
elle j'ai vu pleurer jean
systématiquement sur ce thème sensible à
ces trucs là comme je pourrai jamais que
l'émission pop com
rires oui parce que je me considère pas
justement comme supérieur à qui faut
parce que comme dans le temps c'est
peut-être un peu plus à la mode que je
célèbre aîné a clairement changé mais la
société exane est aussi vraiment changé
aussi c'est un reflet de celui ci si oui
exact fait que on écoutait c'est au
début était curieusement les maquis
faisant en sorte que c'était fait qu'on
a commencé que tu aimes
qui sait on on est juste devenu accro
notre lot comme python justement les
deux mouches avaient jeté contre après
contre lui aussi pieds on s'était comme
vraiment de down take up a commenté ont
réagi à chacun comme des compléments et
c'est tellement drôle comme mais on
était réellement divertissant réellement
divertissement qui puisse affecter ceux
qui s'opposent dire que je pense que
quand tu sors de l'eau puis justement
tout comme une espèce de coop
lytton de ford gt matech
tout était dans un monde la banque a
déjà reçu combien de temps
petit sort de leur petit comme c est aux
portes je comprends qu'une opportunité
plus il doit vivre justement comme si
espèce de thé comme solitude parce que
tu es comme kit pour le sentiment comme
de mérite ont été comme en même temps je
suis une personne qui ont dû que de la
valeur j'y fais des trucs et comment je
peux comme je sais ça fait que tu es
comme dans ces zones manfo club mais
c'est comme ça que je l'imaginé puis le
jeu mais je pense a récemment pu avec ce
paquet sujet comme je trouve que c'est
tellement un exemple 21 des bons
exemples justement de l'école qui est
comme des sites phares comme cuba c'est
ce que je vois comme phare de quoi de
positif avec ceux qui pourraient le
podcast tellement respecté m'a écoutée
par attac et fixe est tellement comment
transformer une saison où tu écopes qui
stoppe peu comme pas au point un hasard
parce que clairement les gens sont
attachés à toi qui aimes tu as ton
l'humain que tu es tout seul mais comme
de transformer cinq jours de positives
comme ce procès comme aix en provence à
toi pour ce vraiment ce qu on s'entend
que la majorité des gens parce que je
bataille peut peut-être se généralise à
100 mais essayez juste de coop
systématiquement tout ce qu'ils trouvent
une façon de répandre les valeurs peu
importe comment un pompiste jardinières
le sheed comment je peux monétiser - le
mans puis à coup sûr une réflexion comme
normal quand je me maquille patès après
que mon médecin je préfère avoir fait
mon métier drive au travail comment
trouver en fait un peu l'impro c'est
caen qui est ménagé ce pilot même temps
ça me tente pas leur tournée comme un
serveur à québec fait qu'est ce que je
fais et que le gamin je fais pour catch
attack si ça fait que tu te le dire que
c'est tentant crise de prendre des
décisions qui sont contre
l'objectif global et wii puis c'est sûr
que là tout comme justement une grande
fan de podcasts puis de ramener tous
l'expérience humaine
si tu peux vraiment plus touché
quelqu'un qu'une conversion de deux
routes voies dites dans les sujets qui a
pourtant des photos sur instagram
c'est ce qui nous reste et qui posait
qu'elles sont en tout comment qu'on dira
la vérité avec sept épis pauvres et tg
s'est doté le type 0 connu quand paris
ap hp a pointé mais tant qu'on reçoit
des messages du genre hey genre j'ai
arrêté de fumer grâce à vous j'en
remercie en crise ou si ou ça et je
commence à m'entraîner parce que vous
mettez vous en parlait souvent quel
point c'est bon ça va dans même si ses
fans c'est gratifiant au passage
dernièrement sur facebook on comptera
près mais un message sur facebook c'est
madame qui disait qu'il y avait eu une
instit journée de mardi
ces pics à travailler dans comme support
je pense je ne me rappelle plus
exactement je me suis la personne qui
écrit pour puma rapidement mme lemay a
travaillé dans le support à des femmes
qui avaient des problèmes le thé dans
leur ville puis elle après une journée
complète entendre juste des femmes comme
déferler leurs problèmes à sentais
vraiment dingue
il avait une heure une histoire à faire
pour s'emmener cherbourg à retourner
chez eux et à écouter le podcast audio
est arrivé chez nous peut jeter bien y
croire
[Rires]
j'aimerais qu'il y ait plus de place au
québec
oui j'aimerais vraiment il ya beaucoup
de monde qu'on a rencontré qu'on se dit
qu'il risque d'autres cieux plus de
place dans société 50
mais oui vraiment humblement
l'impression de faire une différence
le tipi voter coûte de quelque chose
s'investit le titre et oui c'est drôle
parce que tu te tente au petit bout ça
m'arrive peau à toutes les semaines mais
rien que du monde qui viennent de rater
le guide podcast en allemand puis c'est
arrivé à quelques reprises de jardin
j'arrive pas à croire que c'est toi qui
m'a également fait j'essaye le plus
rapidement possible de genre ouais on
est relégables je te poses des questions
puis on est juste deux - qui gère ce
genre crise moi plus spécial
mais c'est ce public amateur si ce film
est ton je vois pas non plus juste et
qui les commentaires postés en reste
parce que parce que tu es à m'amener 14
soit facile de facile de ses poumons de
le contrôler ans et plus haute que tu es
le ou titoff latex mais après ça comment
vous passez quelques mois comme
justement parler des à des tentes ou
plus sérieusement si une des choses que
j'avais beaucoup chez cette fille là sic
m comment tu fais pas la recette et le
lac la carapace la plus saine et sereine
comme je sais pas vous mais le moral est
bon qu'on s'y
il ya vraiment il ya vraiment une espèce
de mai un espèce de mépris généralisé
pour les influenceurs de plus en plus de
ses dents société j'écoutais hier la
souris est encore jeune avec c'était
rosalie bon enfant qui était largement
le festival d'été nathalie petrowski
pire aux éleveurs enfants c'était le
festival de on n'aime pas les
interventions à faire un discours selon
elle est comme l'exemple on sait en tant
qu ils viennent en france est un exemple
qui a bien commandé des doigts ce soit
mais placer les influenceurs en faisant
comme si elle mettait une alors que
tisse une personnalité connue le flou
comme si j'allais tout à fait cette
émission influençant mettons tout ici
défie les dessus et loire ça non mais
c'est quoi ce qu ils font allusion aux
français mais il parle de mais je pense
je pense qu'il va être comme ça parce
que c'est parce que j'allais avec tout
ce savoir faire la cdc moi je trouve que
c'est time la passe est un leurre mais
je trouve que ce mépris la est justifié
pour certaines personnes je trouve qu'il
ya eu un problème qui grossit
tranquillement comme d'adulation mais où
est ce que je voulais arriver avec ça
c'était que une personne comme elisabeth
riou le monde n'ont aucune idée comment
c'est légitime tous connaissent
si aucune des parce que oui c'est assez
bon sur instagram wam et aucune des
pièces qui est derrière ce n 'est pas
n'ai pas trahi faute ce genre d'action
malheureusement le pied c'est tellement
dommage de devoir simplifie aussi
facilement mais la réalité c'est que la
grande majorité après bien sûr comme
plusieurs raisons plus spécifiques mes
pieds puis varier le méjean la réalité
s'est servi bout
la jalousie 20 noms jokela comme pauvres
est elle aujourd'hui comme pour casser
la tête tant que ça c'est juste que
comme elle pour certaines personnes je
pense qu'elle symbolise comme parce que
son corps est fait de telle façon parce
que le les cheveux blancs par ce qui est
très mauvaise parce que leur quartier
jara symbolise comme le comme l'a chanté
comme le manque de confiance qui s'est
développée au fait les années pour
certains heures puis le fait que comme
réussie finale avec grâce à ses com
devenu un symbole symbolise le fait
capitaliser sur du vide languit mais
c'est sûr mais je le sur le superficiel
mais je trouve ça justement dommage
parce que c'est clairement le fait que
comme son corps et comme de manière
hasardeuse comme fait comme ce que c'est
là que moi j'ai vraiment un problème
avec ça c'est comme des filles comme
s'émanciper comme entraîneur mais cech
elles sont quand les gens faibles
pourquoi alors et polo loi comme je vois
tellement de contradictions folle là
dedans qui m'attend si tu es une fille
comme un peu plus grand du genre que
s'occuper d'eux comme 250 livres gens
s'impliquent arena qui fera la même à
fatwas on serait comme ces gens c'est
juste 3 lorraine - le droit le monde
ferait sous mavendra powell lui répond
un point de vue de millionnaires soit la
cia elle-même following a raison mais
mais où t'apprends la raison tantôt
raison en fait c'est sûr mais c'est
juste au niveau de la liberté
individuelle de la personne comme et ce
qu'ils soient rend la balle comme
pourquoi seraient limités sous vêtements
parce que comme ça fit avec un stade qui
honnêtement peu importe son corps le jeu
cette file system and hard work yousfi
potentiellement briand est tellement
jeune tellement cher pays comme brillant
et doute comme je vais à son ange leur
succès lors du casse le monde
connaissait pas ce moment à l'opie c'est
ce qu'on s'est dit après ce genre
tabarnak alex fait le pack away with me
prévient la ceni au sein des piscines
non non nicole resté surpris tout le
monde s'était créé c'est à gérer trois
pages instagram de cas de sa business a
posté les photos par acti on a de la
misère à gérer petit la foire de loin à
gérer des lancements gérer des nouveaux
maillots etc alors que kevin ce podcast
21 jan un sens des affaires le pipeau
juste pour elle mme attias c'est comme
si à donner des versions dans l'aide à
faire ou à vous d'essayer s'appuie elle
une telle adversaire subséquente à
chaque fois ci pas la meilleure idée
quand c'est incroyable c'est faux c'est
vraiment dommage que les gens aient
tendance à baisser sur les causes encore
fait fort petits mousses jerry quelques
jours de l'ampleur de ce café frais je
dormirai pas duré trop laxiste et non je
n'irai pas la nuit ont directement fait
ce puits bâti sur mac est pas toujours
facile à contrôler
gc
c'est foutu mais elle met on est rendu à
l'étape où est ce que l'homme a peut
avoir des idées qui disparaît du monde
pour réaliser ses idées fait ça ça va
être le meilleur boutleux c'est parce
qu'on débute un genre de trois ans ou
est-ce que tu étais d'un bois de 6 ans
de chypre et à former une voiture s'est
engagée du monde pierre à gérer les
idées ça c'est peut-être pour une
personne comme elle sèchement le cac est
approché pour une colère bleue qui
sépare cette table à la marche et le
démesuré
je pense que la fête un peu sadique
qu'elle avait mis 75000 pia sans pub
puis que le maillot avait soda août
avant que la première pub s'apprend pas
non mais oh ouais ouais c'est ce qu'elle
avait dit c'est qu'elle avait mis de
l'argent en pub sur des influences or
sauf que avec la coop besoin avant
premières peuvent soit en ligne yooz le
maillot et soldats
oui c'est même pas vu ce soit des
bêlements est incroyable mais oui ça
marchait des valeurs comme des délits la
raison pour moi j'ai comme autant de
respect entre eux pour cette personne ne
sait que au niveau de la collaboration
ces gens c'est irrespectueux c'est
sérieusement à hama juste comme les six
faire ce que je veux c'est pas mal
jusqu'à votre nokia finalement non comme
et j'avais comme ça me fait comme fond
de confiance après j'aurai comme des
idées un peu ici là bien sûr comme ma
benz benz m mais c'est vraiment gentil
qu'on ne refasse que ces averses a
besoin de ça pour avoir l'air comme de
machines comme quoi il y en a bien sûr
comme le naqab il quitte l'armée car
bien sûr mais à gers comme moi je gère
mes trucs dansant scop telmar comme
authentiquement et par le fils et sa
fille
ces pauvres gens qu'il faut que je
quitte ans qu'est ce qui marche que ça
comme on apprend compte mais jean
honnêtement c'est pour
c'est tellement les bris naturel et
authentique jean sérieusement sur la mer
colada est vrai pour un artiste c'est
comme crazy pim fait que c'est ça
vraiment été ouais on continue à faire
des trucs votre design s'était fait
copier par compagnie web le match mais
les deux sont les deux premiers sont
sortis se sont fait c'est un vol en
plein jour à côté c'est pas du plagiat
passé comme complicité mère-fils pas
compris mais le plagiat c'est sûr ce
serait comme de prendre d'imagés de
l'imprimé puis de dire mais ils y ont
copié l'idée les couleurs se serait fait
le destin ne peut pas amener quelqu'un
au repos mais c'est une campagne comme
énorme tire les avais je pense qu'elle
est comme un point 8 ou qu'elle soit 2
millions followers pied s'affola non
comme je pense 10 millions affectées
sont qui ont fait hacker devant figeac
ouest
j'ai jamais autant reçu de message de
comme boxeur comme pour rester comme une
espèce de appuyé là en même temps ça me
stressait de fuck out parce que
honnêtement cette thématique là au
complet si on maîtrise tellement je
trouve que c'est un pur d'énergie n'est
pas relevé jean leplat
et c'est beaucoup d'énergie négative
puis en parler parce qu'on a des jeunes
et zabeth et moyens comme deux jours
avec son tir mais tout peut on parler de
ce truc lopy jeu contente qu'elle ait eu
la même réaction que moi moi je sentis
plus tu risques de te voir le champo
quelqu'un tentant d'arracher de l'argent
des mains parce que tu es en train de
faire une copie comme j'ai jamais connue
je préfère le voir demain j'ai jamais
connu cet argent le j'ai jamais eu la
possibilité d'avancer dans ce genre n
existe pas de maillot et sur le banc
mais d'antan oui la marche assez bien ça
serait comme quasiment greedy d'être
comme mais ce serait pas que ministre et
lille c'est légitime
être comme banana c'est quand même très
légitime comme action s'il est difficile
d'estimer si c'est plus stressant pour
moi que que comme positive envie de
penser à ces chutes le comme c'est pas
la première fois je me fais plagié
commises depuis très longtemps jean pied
des compagnies comme quasiment mort y
est heureusement base et son copilote ou
surtout dans une certaine période dans
ma vie parce que maintenant il comme
pleine grogne qui se mit vont dans la
lignée de com à des jeux de mots avec t
d d d imagerie qui ne sont pas plaints
en mai dans le temps le lieu comme 5 6
ans les gens il y en avait un trop
vraiment le site comprend camaris a
juste commencé à papier tout puis je
pense que j'étais j'aurai peu de soleil
à quelques années par soir été comme
trop générale en mai je pense qu'avec du
recul je peux le dire comme justin fait
que genre oui je pense que comme t il
beaucoup de gens comme influences il se
sait
parce que oui mais après ça se fait que
deco plus locaux que laisse comme un peu
plus mal et souvent peut-être même
boutique est supprimée mullen et mangez
jamais rien parce que je regrette juste
au niveau humain je lis comme l'univers
se charger de ce bon sens pau comme je
te souhaite d'être réprimandé mais
prudents en ce club tchèque jan tout le
monde se cherche tout le monde avec
l'ère d'internet est un grand mais du ce
comme le pine trail c'est tout comme les
images les gens ce qu'ils cherchent
l'inspiration comme tout le monde
cherche de l'inspiration cette façon là
maintenant donc c'est comme un peu une
période où woods pour les créateurs
clairement il ya des gens qui payent la
santé comme été repéré par mon star
d'hannah ça ressemble trop pige à spa
caveau comme se définit elle même qui se
développer elle-même autres comme un
rappeur ou un musicien qui à la base
c'est sûr quand tu commences à faire de
la musique peut toujours quelque chose
que tu connais par un chiffrement
mais j'essaie de le voir de même je
commette et en début de carrière guy
mais tu cherches vous avez idéalement
genre juste pour tomber à toi je
souhaiterais que cette passe le mieux
possible on temps parce que
l'originalité c'est la clef de tout
succès jean puis l'authenticité aussi
fake je te souhaite pour tobin comme de
sortir de ce le plus rapidement possible
parce que le single hot pursuit soit
toujours avoir la copie d'un chip
hornsby mais de quelque chose d'autre
mes jambes mais c'est plus au niveau
humain comme moi j'ai pas envie d'aller
comme humilié cette personne l'eau aux
lèvres puis surtout pas publiquement
j'en serai jamais capable de faire
sauter plus haut c'est comme pour un des
deux côtés de ses amis nous avons cette
capacité là justement de comme blast et
publiquement qu'un pauvre est agencé
juste min yé vraiment qu'un changement
c'est vraiment une bonne du puits mais
dans le cas de la grosse compagnie vous
l'avez quand les opposants
non je pense que fait heins une story à
margny déjà avec une autre femme et ses
come and stay pour jean alicot comme une
seule magie éviter sujet complètement je
suis pas vraiment hills a [ __ ] vous
avez normale de l'est ses abonnés
sûrement à embarquer aussi ouais ouais
ouais il avait le fait je pense que
c'est correct aussi pigeage là je la
comprends je pensais juste parce que moi
dans mon quotidien je cherche et comme
j'avais j'ai parfois envie je trouve à
cannes saint sébastien est l'objet
je n'avais pas envie de recevoir un
million de notification d'accord je
voyais que ça sent la laine de postes en
finlande allemagne et comme poker face
et comme une compagnie chinoise comme
énorme qui ont des capacités de
production en libye le mental sais même
pas qui est derrière ces camps et
compagnie obscur gens travaillent sur le
com oui si tu cherches tu vas trouver
mais comme si seul si seul appareil que
cette campagne lot et maintenant je
prends l'exemple jean philippe sire la
cuisine de jean philippe est en fait un
vidéo d'un bel outil vegan inquiet puis
hellmann's la compagnie de mayonnaise
or fait une vidéo c'est la même recette
puis la vidéo c'est dans le monde
marcil et damon qui font tous genres
cissé malouda menez ou non mais de la
mayo hellmann's viggen juste les mains
ils vont changer
c'est les mêmes qui ont changé mais
maintenant le jeu vidéo les plans mais
le pain c'est la même chose c'est le
même vidéo que jean-philippe par les
réseaux sociaux il ya deux mois ce n'est
pas la première fois que ça m'arrive de
qu'une recette soit prise deux mois puis
en cuisine en cuisine tu peux pas il
n'ya pas aucun recours
je peux pas rien faire puis lui c'est
pour la première fois depuis je me tais
parce que il rien que ça et 27 août les
récits de ces derniers ça ça revient au
même après midi sauf que là se saisit
des eaux comme trop pressé de la même
chose et je trouve ça donne un peu le il
dit j'ai écrit à elle manie sauf que
d'autres comme la foule c'est qui a fait
ça c'est qu'ils les autres ont juste et
on a juste répondu comme on va envoyer
sur un autre équipe de création
tchécoslovaquie le cas de l'amérique
puis après ça y est j'ai entendu
reparler d'études si c'est comme le
monde au dessus de tuer les boss d'un an
glissant calice dessus parce qu'ils sont
pas légalement dans le trouble le lieu
que fait ce il va peut-être faire taper
ses doigts si yacine monde qui en
parlent mais va pas perdre sa job pour
avoir fait ça tout le monde s'en crise
le dessus ouais il a même pas de recours
la drastique comme surprise parce que
j'aurais l'impression sa compagnie oui
énorme compagnie mais tu peux
éventuellement arriver à quelque chose
et comme le film non je pense pourtant
que c'était trop groupe qui arrive un
clic ce soit le tout je pense que tout
le monde ment sur company lawson
légitimement les affaires légales qui
peuvent te permettre de faire quoi que
ce soit aussi ça la fatigue ces
compagnies le chemin tout en fait même
pas trois jours plus tard plus personne
en parle sur le vivant pas mal moins
bien dormir le space est certaine on
exactement si c'est toi qui en souffre
loin mais justement c'est ainsi qu'en
fait c'est c'est que tout le monde est
comme perdant dans ces situations à
moins que justement tu t'acharnes en
est-il pour comme finalement comme te
fare entendez trouver une solution ou
récupérer du cash vous avez vu mais
c'est sur des compagnies énorme comme ce
genre il y aura des avocats aux oublis
seul tu peux rien faille aux infinies
cage un pitch le mot la fin c'est un
sentiment d'impuissance extrêmement
frustrant et toxique est pour ce que je
voulais comme juste coupé secours parce
que de recevoir des échos de ce au
quotidien si j'en reçois encore au moins
comme genre 10 par jour des gens comme
encore le pszaf un bootleg si comme
chacun sait qu'ils reviennent positif de
ce fait c'est mettons ça peut pas faire
un jour des faits déjà éclaire mayotte
et en copie pour unis pleut ça fait
parler pour nibali pour plusieurs
artistes j'avais vu l'exemple enersys de
l est je me sais pas c'est quoi son nom
mais zara avec sommes repris ces patchs
et ou pièces émanent qui est devenu
connu motifs parce que c'est devenu une
espèce de corps qui symbolisait ce que
beaucoup d'artistes vivait au tour du
monde à commencer la mode c'est c'est
devenu une espèce d'exemple pui s à le
bénéficier grandement parce que genre
tout le monde est reprise par exemple
jean veil se prenait faisait artica
promoteur a fait quelques passes a
entrevu un million de fois plus jeune
que ça fait quand même le sait comment
on va encourager comme la vraie artiste
et que ça peut être intéressant fut
apprécié faut vraiment trouver comme ans
d'art qui est devenu le porte parole de
rome ce combo le ski une naïve chose à
faire parce que c'est un combat qui doit
être menée parce que c'est vrai que
c'est plus facile que jamais que deux
plats gigean des images de l'artiste
était trop souvent l'impression que tout
ce qui sort internet leur a pas de
feeling vraiment fucked up que tout le
monde
e puis beaucoup de gens apprennent à la
dure que ce scepticisme un intrus dans
ton vidéo la musique dans l'internet
je peux te faire mention moi j'ai
souvent eu ces craintes l'homme et plus
par rapport comme quand je jouais avec
des symboles la culture pop les moutons
comme dirait qu'ils sont montchanin
enfin plus à ce niveau là de comme
personnel
jeunes ou encore ibn al ala puis un
exemple de ce qui avait bien virer mais
on n en sait quelque chose qui me
tracasse c'est tout le temps je t'ai
j'en ai même comme caisse réussi à
l'être déjà toutes les autres images
c'est ce happy tabou couteau par kanté
dans l'inconnu qui connaît pas des lois
par rapport à mai d'extême des roches un
peu gentil comprend que c'est énorme ce
cas par cas cela veut commercialiser mon
tee shirt avec avec marc est très bien
pour moi mais avec bye des tic et tac de
marquer tu l'a peut-être que les
héritiers de notre histoire est
poursuivi pour utilisation
mais j'ai déjà dit comme c'est quoi la
pire superbement placé comme bayod jolie
dakota calcul c'est marrant mais une
histoire de nice est arrivée avec les
chefs et de shanghai de drake ce que moi
j'écoutais degrassi nouvelle génération
et puis c'est jimmy en chaise roulante
[Musique]
mais si je me faisais tu es ce sera le
haut tellement fonctionner puis au début
cherché comme tellement mal à l'aise et
moi j'avais une famille comme très
croyante à marc vds azaria du genre
comme ultra catholique et où donc
j'avais le cateau les guides même
jusqu'à comme tous les ans mais ça
revient au score mais le malaise avec
l'argent puis à voir comme une espèce de
réussite comme financière
ça me fait sentir comme pour imiter
comme espèce de comme malaise comme
énorme accepte ça me même des plats
d'anna nicole 20e été comme énormément
comme tanné de me parler mais ça stresse
comme vraiment grandjean qui vient juste
de catholiques guillaudeau déjà c'est
moi quand j'ai vu ma mère a dormi par
terre
parce que j'en ai marre là c'était de
trop qui comprend bien le fait c'est
comme une période de temps ça poserait
comme éternellement mais c'est quand
même si la marque est dans tout et tout
et wes et puis comme que le luxe spawn
36 contrat ça prend pas beaucoup ça les
mines du luxe ok c'est pas la relève
cette malade que tu est élevé les
quintés jeune scénographe pas mal tous
les styles
c'est comme le chef pour l'acq est
souvent terrasses et jardins truc là
comme d'enfance en fermier toujours
c'est les grands les grands thèmes qui
fait que ce chant elle avait comme
tellement bien marché comme on est déjà
arrêté de la france était trop malade
qu'il faut commencer à travailler comme
les y en a trop dit sk peut être bref
[Applaudissements]
des milieux centaines de milice est
juste et quand un confortable avec
l'idée que c'est parce qu'il faut rester
dans le début puis sharks en train de
m'adapter à les autres et pourtant c'est
ce mot c'est ce que je trouve nice de
toi c kit est clairement une artiste
d'abord c'est ce qui définit mais de
transformer ce business par
l'entrepreneur ensuite tous les artistes
deviennent des outils web mais aussi des
fourmis annexant moins bon des fauteuils
en discute alors mais c'était trop
business at ça perverti trucks ou se
prostituent afin de genre de circuit
déjà non non ça reste très stx à rester
c'est pas parce que c'est pas parce que
tu as enfin pas tant parce que c'est
populaire que ça remet en valeur ce qui
ne touche pas vraiment ce que c'est vrai
que l'idée que tout de l'artiste
ces questions ago piste et prudence 3
gobain qui excuse moi honnêtement au
québec on entretient lui il est mandaté
le sénégal que tu parles le québec l'eau
dans son adn c'est comme l'adn ce qui
est exact des bilans le québec
ils veulent s est entendu tellement
souvent la phrase supporter un artiste
supportons qu'aux artistes locaux j'aï
cette france là comme si un artiste
devait faire pitt singh pour qu'on a
dans son ensemble son poster son nez
parce que comme par définition voyez
comme imiter nommé mary beth comme de
kout fokine par jean comme il est vrai
pour happy comme c'est vrai mais une
phrase qu'on utilise un supporter comme
je comprends qu'ils aient une bonne
intention derrière ça mais d'autres gens
devraient acheter le truc parce que
senna est aussi attendu que d'autres qui
viennent si petit mal assuré qu'on
devrait assurer comme pire c'est qu'on
aurait consommé localement puis on
devrait clairement comme regarder le
temps long tour de nous observer et le
lac l'animé genre supporter comme si
l'artiste faisait optique un port est
effectif c'est ce qui c'est notre
intérêt qui fait en sorte qu
éventuellement quand l'artiste commence
à marcher plus parfait exemple
inquiet de fire ou limite il ya
tellement d'artistes qui viennent de
montréal piquion make it puis dès que tu
commences à avoir là un petit peu trop
comme billie jean financièrement on peut
imaginer comme conforta financièrement
bello bien sur ses jambes
on est [ __ ] dans ac2 comme test ce
bombardement
parce que comme melty de la correcte
fait que ces banlieues et on attend sans
arrêt comment ce que les autres
connaissent pas mais comme moi je
connais dans la musique par exemple
fallu c'est le meilleur exemple
kft championnat voir les sorties premier
album c'était comme tout le monde capote
et state street est la chose la plus
stupide accord a encore un secret bien
gardé même s'ils avaient un bon plat
préfet l'usam album troisième album le
hope quatrième album aussi à risque
avoue aussi que la qualité est là plus
diminué pour la cinquième album qui
montrait j'étais allé voir la tournée et
la dernière tournée qui ont fait envoyer
son vidéotron est allé voir les voir un
show parce que ça a été mon band par une
période était bien traitée à temps des
deux soeurs bleues 2003 babou cissé
c'est mon band jour j'ai capoté
l'excellent ben c'est petit mais
monsieur moins typé sur le banc après si
je dois rester fidèle si aubaine que
j'ai tripé ci est allé voir un show
ouais elle est bon show il y avait pas
un hipster une en place les visiteurs
avaient déserté mais oui c'est ce noble
avait quitté le banc
si c'est ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils les
éditeurs vont être les premiers à tout
prix insensés les nouvelles affaires
type mais ils vont être les premières à
bardonecchia qui vont juger que c'est
plus poussif
c'est comme traitement et 35 ans et plus
ainsi plus de gens qui apprécient je me
sens moins comme si j'étais dans un club
sélect de fins connaisseurs mélomanes
comme l'exact oui tout cas je voudrais
pas que toi c'est sa fête sont un peu
sur notre faim qu'ils comme une espèce
de pop est en ébullition comme nice nice
tenait à préciser quand même succès
populaire pulsé oui ça fait là est bien
trop pourquoi tout le monde je me suis
aussi un million de fois genre à et
malin touche m à beille où je sais moi
et mes amis j'en aurais fait payer un
ami tout pêche
hewson j'ai glissé puis ses jambes elle
tout le monde le linge à l'ananas je
vais quand même prendre à tout le monde
le vscan blessant même des amis où
vivait sa d'autres comme si sarkozy
mais comme chaque plage voit ces gens
comment être aux personnes qui ont
répondu ce cas comme je comprends mais
tous ces gentils comme une des mères est
venue calmer parce que malgré huit
heures sup mais c'était ma oui mais je
pense que ça vient toucher à des ondes
très importante humaines fondamentales
de comment je me dis fini en tant que
personne comment je m'identifie et comme
ceux ci une espèce de valeur woods au
fait de comme si toi tu es dans un
nouveau mouvement qui a potent 2 août
watts écouter le podcast obscur man dès
qu'un podcast d'avis comme trop
populaire en ans c'est comme ça pue
je veux qu'on ramasse comme simple
unique ctu pense à vis d'un profond
manque de confiance pour de brillants
c'est un profond manque de confiance
pensant que les thèmes centraux
populaires sont trop comme tu es comme
un genre donc c'est d'ailleurs une chose
que je trouve n'a effectué sous elle est
présentement c'est tout sauf triste
c'est quelque chose d'alternative pareil
d'un compromis colle tant pis qui se
souvient d'un podcast d'un rythme
d'expansion d'oublier palais maillot la
chose la pomme était sans offense le
ticket pour nom les arnaques il peu
large et la plus collants dim et avec
laquelle s'associent mais tant pis si je
pars je pense réellement que des noms
connus reçue mi temps de certains
artistes que c'est comme si mon image à
cette image tanguay je trouve ça naze
que tu mets ton toi qui fonde avec
d'autres gens qui pensent comme ça mais
sérieusement ça fait pas passer par une
seconde gt gens sont déçus par smart
j'ai déjà regardé les podcasts je trouve
comme vraiment enrichissant pourquoi je
me bloquerait de 7,2 cette interaction
lab si jamais je pense pas beaucoup à
ces trucs-là nettement moins de com
image que les autres pour travaux par
rapport à dans quelle catégorie maître
telle activité ou tél bojan projet je me
crispe a major justement les mains
exemple s'ils habitent les cpge à se
quitter comme kinect c'était sur surface
c'est acheter comme toutes les
rencontres ici les termes en effet tout
le moins sérieusement cette fille
commençait raconte riis et que mais on a
fait l'émission mais moi c'est pourquoi
mieux la danse
c'est pourquoi on s'est vu une fois à
l'espèce de projection comme intime de
la syrie puis d'apcher comme trop gêné
je pensais pas une bonne chose jusqu'à
partir on a envie de foncer pas tant
parler qui après ça a été tu as triché
comme entendu qui a tripé foule camara
m'avait dit qu'on fasse défaut sur ce
que je fais et je faisais pas plus cher
passe moi le sens à leurs rangs plus
haut qui s'appelait comme l'on dit que
j'avais fait une vitrine de noël avec
comme un pin's cette pique vraiment plus
grand des cambistes
mais entre bref cinquième est allé à ce
que pop up shop le qui a les gens tout
achever son corps mais pour le premier
de ses pieds pour la connaissons cette
fille je donnerai tout mais arrêtez à y
croire mais en fait non à l eau comme
acheter plein de trucs récemment par les
pierres mais qui paie comme you
j'aimerais stéphane crémer hamon n'a pas
pas l'âge commence à poster des photos
d'eux avec mes trucs hamon ne jamais
parler à maurienne demandé à être allés
acheter par elle-même et des comme yossi
tellement hâte entité morigène me
parlait tellement sincèrement de
qu'est-ce que ça le fait sentir quand on
était à lille je suis déjà intéressant
et plus sérieusement pied je sais c'est
qu'à part son propre jeu sans rien
retirer de sa commence a posté les
photos cl photoshoot a commencé à porter
méchant des touches déjà là déjà tu es
tombé ce mardi matin comme c'est dedans
mais
c est comme cela et humain mais gingka
ces photos tu te fais peut-être une idée
de pâques à 508 city aucun flash la
personne je ne sais pas pourquoi parler
de ça mais par apparaît que le monde qui
te marrer tech que tout faire seul oui
c'est ça y était comme des surfaces
planes bonne association qui touche déjà
d'autres bercy luminaires yassine avait
rencontré cette ville de 6 où je
n'aurais pas fait mon qui dit non à d
énormes compagnie d'environ je me mets
pas dans des situations parce qu'il fit
le bilan est bon j'ai filé papier jeune
fils est fait pour moi c'est fini
l'appui jeu quand même dans des
écoulements respect quant au respect
mutuel
j'ai envie d'en face à projets en
maîtrise et après c'est parce que je
suis dans avec le message 4 oui fait ce
feeling le reste vraiment souvent un
institut de bombay de georges eux le
fils tout je fais le porter tous leurs
atouts leur foi aux autres cultes et
d'enfants tue plus d'enfants mais si tu
le feeling de t-shirts son fils dans le
good feeling il vaut vraiment ce que
l'appui du moins moi j'ai tendance pour
l'écouter à ces genres de me dire à qui
le rend pas dans quelque chose sans
vraiment réfléchir
à l'espèce de petite voix qui me disait
mais c'est pas possible je les fait
souvent dernières années les deux camps
réalisé kaki non non non c'était
personnel et sa seule c'était pacifique
mais il prévient que tu t'embarques te
fais aussi le 1/2 gillet préféré avec
busta oui c'est tout finito way dont je
lègue du store lester genre s'était déjà
des saucisses qui a stimulé le stand et
ce fut décapité la sécession et pizzas
je pense qu'il y avait comme un gros
présentoirs avec toutes les tee-shirts
au festival de cannes de montréal
j'arrive juste des tee-shirts ou le
monde de gustave est ce t-shirt le
fameux carré le guichetier qui est une
seule nation
c'est comme des séances avec des phares
des éléments de pizzas selon ces images
un cas plusieurs heures plusieurs
compagnies take it approche pour faire
des trucs comme un pis faut que je fasse
un triangle tu peux pas et oui il faut
se fasse un trépied oui j'ai un bonheur
et une bonne histoire parra passe mes
fesses formation mais il ya comme 4
environ si je fais cette jeunesse est
inquiète pochette d'album parce que moi
ma vraie passion c'est la musique plein
passons mais comme nous ne l'avons plus
grande et bonne défense et les musées
etc et puis j'ai toujours été entouré de
beaucoup de musiciens puis la majorité
de mes amis sont dans des bonnes gens
sont impliqués de près ou de loin dans
le mille d'amuser fixé ce puis j'ai
commencé comme ça à la base à faire de
l'art quand j'étais jeune au cégep je
veux des flyers pour des shows qui n'est
pas celle d'album c'est même que j'ai
vraiment commencé de siham inspirant de
la musique puis en créant comme une
image qui que je chantais kiki qui était
représentative pour comme sète ou non ou
cet album l'homme et que c'est ce qui
s'est passé ça commençait de même fait
que j ai toujours peu comme
pré cité par association dans ce milieu
l'homme est un manet cgt sur le site de
csm pour écouter l'émission d'un ami
puis j'ai vu le palmarès puis dans le
palmarès y avait aujourd'hui c'est pas
cher j'en avais fait le zhejiang disent
venir à tahiti on parlait comme du tri
de comme ça va c'est tout du monde que
j'ai aimés puis que je respecte et puis
que je tête d'andre de participer à leur
projet mais à manille je me suis comme
tu disais tantôt akissi tête en bas 35
ans jean py tu puisses tu veux quelque
chose de kibati oui à ce train
l'association après ça moi je commets je
trouve ce du nice que tu pense à moi
mais je pense que pour ton produit juste
pour te démarquer en général fait les
hommes qui vont assurer en est sa valise
tout est mis à mal et mon honnêteté
marie curie devant identiques à ceux qui
voient là pour toi
vinci comme en espère un peu dans l'eau
puis se shoote l'aude comme palmarès csm
sam arriveront marque tchèque la couche
à kiel le fauve riz et même faux je dise
non
même si je les adore qu'il les aime
comme fausse disent non parce que pour
eux parce que moi je disais moi je veux
que ça marche ça comme toute la donne et
de la même place le brader c'est vrai
que ça fait que ça vaut dix fois on veut
papillon en s on est content mais c'est
le contenu qui veut mais oui bien sûr
mais on s'entend que comme l'image on se
sent devenir la même place
c'est pas bon quand on creuse mais je
sais encore sarah sont pour eux mais
j'ai décidé de cela qu en est-il
vraiment se prendre comme dit les
projets spécifiques en salle tentait
vraiment pire c'est pire
guedjali même est arrivé avec la haute
lutte il ya quelques années pour l'album
dernier record grand fan
non non mais continue ton histoire parce
qu'ils sont mais non mais en fait moi
j'ai trouvé ça va me les stalles et
croire comme une rose la planète donc
quand il me l'a demandé c'était comme au
japon plus tôt puis jetés en face aux
intentions
bref une coupe d'un hôpital est revenue
pim il était jarriot je vais vraiment ça
soit touaffeck genton peut-il fanon qui
la bonne je l'étais mans et mimé
chantait pour que mon site
c'est le bon pour leur présence comme en
face lebron la main dans la main toute
la main non mais j'ai dit non mais
j'allais perdre mais c'est ça l'histoire
c'est que j'ai jeté tellement j'aurais
dû aussi à des moments où je réside
demong a fait part j digestifs comme
plus sérieux que ce qu'on pense que j'ai
une bonne impression que c'est le cas en
tunisie
je pense pas que c'est la bonne
non non pour rire je veux non comme
doudou dis que j'en ils veulent
s'asseoir jambes et pieds moi je sais
fauqué d'honorer mais ça m'a tellement
demi dans un maroc
oui je te mangerais écouté mon gars de
feeling s'est littéralement jean le
chiffre de plus difficile que j'ai
jamais eu enfin parce que j'aimais
tellement à bonn justement viscéralement
genre marqué par la musique
j'étais capable chez ce jour mais depuis
ceux-ci boukadous avait jeté comme si
pauvre oui de connecter des chaises aux
suppôts la bonne personne pour façon si
ça devrait pas être apte unis pensent
qu'à leur époque six coloris ça ne
devrait plus comme plus réaliste ou plus
chez peau mais faut que ça soit autre
chose comme à peu près fait que ça a été
un match choc total piger comme moi de
mon point de vue puis de mon point de
vue j'ai coaché ce dépotoir de non j'ai
pas fier panther 2
ce truc là son ca damas je pense que si
j'avais comme il y aurait une j'aurais
pu mieux gérer dans le sens j'aurais
vraiment pu
c'est comme de phoques dame puis
j'espère comme un cube et tchèques se
veut pas que ça soit comme foule
khartoum mais prince reste est
clairement fait plein fabre réaliste
dans ta vie tout ce dont comme passa pas
toujours été ne sont pas plus clairement
capables d'estimer que j'aurais pu
vraiment aller méditer pu tomber dans
une zone puis j'aurais pu faire de quoi
defour gens ça c'est comme mon regret je
pense que j'aurais vraiment pu faire de
quoi de kung fu pour sept matches nuls
mais vu qu'ils me disaient que mon jeu
france assure toi moi ça soit un truc
clé en ouest puis même si la cub est
squatté virus favoris comme non
satisfaits c'était comme faut qu'ils
n'arrivent comme c'est la meilleure
chose que je peux pas me dire mais en
même temps comme je constate un manque
ici pas le bon visuel pour les
chirurgies pas à s'exprimer ce pas ce
que tu voulais le faire ces mêmes femmes
de talent fait que sa fille que je suis
comme ali dans la lignée comme
traditionnelles de mon truc mais je
conserve pas que c'était le bon truc
mais c'est en même temps c'est ce qu'ils
n'en aient souci c'est que tout on danse
et on ne s'est pas compromis piste rue
du pot ni de fraude pour une histoire
parfois comme une boîte de design
graphique toi fin au québec
le sto fait le saut puis jacky jonchère
des pochettes d'album est vraiment
différent même si c'est seulement s'il
vient me chercher pour mon seul parce
que je suis devenu c'est sûr qu'au début
j'ai dans l'idée d'aller dans les
symboles et je demande ça comme
policiers vers l'ip
les contrats quand tu peux le voir mais
non j'en sais ça c'est pas toi mais au
début je me cherchais que l'amant ou si
j'ai commencé tellement jeune que
j'entends encore une exploration quand
je suis devenu entre guillemets jumeux
ton quand j'ai commencé à avoir de
l'attention médiatique nombreux jeux med
comme une exploration ses compatriotes
que je n'étais pas bon ça arrive mais je
pense si ça mais c'est ce afin de
pouvoir se dire ça parce que si tu
penses que tu es abouti ouais temps
normal mais je pense que c'est comme ce
que ces immenses puis ça s'est fait dans
tous mais à nicole notamment vraiment sa
mini par intérim l'autre jour je faisais
le pack assad un mot d'amour il fait pas
de calais le vocabulaire des rapports de
comme haye a fait un truc c'était
gigantesque j'ai fait un tour -qui était
immense sa dernière qu'acs était
gigantesque
le championnat qui est derrière toi qui
t'es ma si je sais que ça s'applique à
tout ben oui si humain c'est ça la fin
c'est que cet art est d'écouter genre
doucement tard elle décide grandi en
somme la cantarelle sa voie d'emprunts
indice phare de ta vie un genre qui est
que les idées trop arrêtez gens par
rapport à un chiffre maintenant à
quelqu'un de super at il vraiment de
gauche jean comme radical est le premier
site que tu défends d'après moi le site
commence à fond l'eau genre d'effort
keane républicain jean lecomte liner
je vous demande à mes joueurs de
vraiment besoin de commencer a tellement
besoin de sortir de ta bulle parce que
tu thème quand tu es dans un cheat de
même je pense que par rapport à quand on
sort des com qui sont comme trop
radicale par rapport à un truc je pense
que suivant le moment où tu devrais huit
ouvriers les yeux par rapport à comme
lampe l'auteur de l'autre côté
l'argumentaire de son côté pour
continuer à réfléchir
c'est dangereux george hâlas le shit que
j'aille plus lors des conversations que
des gens qui sont trop pogné dans leur
vision petit pense que tu penses tu
vraiment qu'agent à 25 ans ses looks de
trouver la vérité c'est vraiment
excellent et nous volent un peu plus au
point de penser que jean africaine 25-23
même 47 top s'il toute trouvée la vire
tab c'est fini pour toi puissance
jusqu'à la fin des jours se défend faut
être calme qui se sait non parce que
toutes les générations ça fait ce dans
les années 60 et ce titre a même affecté
comme pac estime qu'il est fou mes
parents ont fait autorité mais on change
la bombe puis chaque génération c'est ce
qu'il ya un temps d'y penser tout
compris il ya trente ans de feuilleton
minute pour un tacle un peu plus
conservateur parce que leslie j'en ai
partout s'est déployée devant toi tu
essaie de l'éviter mais comme cette ce
fait tant mieux mais c'est vrai qu'ils
ont tout simplement ville entre dole et
que nous agissions vite et j'étais mort
sur le déjà ça n'a pas de bon sens est
agréable et moins qu'acheter kid
je pensais mais soir et se ramasser les
châtaignes mal à 5 milliard on a tout
nouveau nous c'est la plus intéressante
est une autre fois puisque sa g en ce
moment mais ça n'a pas de bon sens
je sais pour revenir parce que ce au
niveau social je suis d'accord qui au
niveau artistique c'est que ça ça peut
faire peur c'est maintenant on veut
prendre un bain de musiques latines et
en prenons metallica comme examen ou
est-ce que là ils font des albums dans
le genre métallique appelée tout le
monde très petit prodige disent qu'est
le dos 100m de faire autre chose c'est
l'iphone autre chose puis ils se font
détruire par tout le monde
ils sont tellement détruire au point où
est ce qu'ils décident de revenir
complètement
c'est enfin dangereux était de mettre en
danger le team et en font deux albums
tout le monde qu apple c'est une saint
leu le dernier single qui vient de
sortir il s'en va ailleurs le 1010 quand
même mitigé
sauf que moi je laime sillage du rebond
c'est ça sonne pas comme les deux
premiers mais je trouve ce rebond
meilleur tokyo le choix sinon c'est quoi
ils font un autre album qui sonne comme
les deux autres pays c'est t'as pas le
choix
banny veut c'est la même chose le oui
les efforts fait deux albums sonnent un
peu pareil ok non la f2 troisième
facultés mentales
le quatrième sans encombre
un jeu pas le choix vos choix ben on
serait ce prix là mais c'est parce que
honnêtement d'après ce que moi je vois
malheureusement sur la cage de l'artiste
y ont malheureusement ça existe puis les
gens ils restent prix là dedans pour
ouvrir parce que puissent aussi à cause
de l'argent c'est vraiment l'eau que
l'argent hilare mais là il ya plusieurs
routes niveau mais ça commence à être
une réelle problématique parce que je
consens tant que s'ils avaient peu de
cash
sakho istres et puis très juste ce prix
ce que tu veux mais je pas sûr que je
peux dire que c'est l'argent comme la
reconnaissance
admettons débat les deux talentueux que
met-on reconnaissance politique
justement mais tel que y ont pu bien
plus besoin d'argent rendu le team
besoin une fois plus de cash le sauf
quelqu'un qui en fait il sort de quoi
peas font juste dire c'est la pire chose
j'ai entendu toute ma vie ouais quand
même que les gens ça me tente pas de
dire on pourrait cacher un certain guy
était pour lui de faire autre chose
après mais on quand tu désires décret
encore des combats du maroc et crée
d'affaires de l'or que le monde airbus
sas espèce de besoin le est-ce que tu
redoutes un moment où est ce que tu dis
ça c'est vraiment toi oui j'y parle non
mais j'adore ce qu'il fait
ces fins de s'imposer que cinq ans j'ai
reposé mais eh ben oui c'est sûr que j'y
pense depuis toujours mais je pense que
justement ce ton argument de plus à
continuer à évoluer grandir
c'est sûr que si on regarde lorsque je
fais dans les douze de nos dernières
années c'est oui ça se ressemble
mais les deux avants - puis les deux
avants genre à caen - mais qu une
évolution georges grandi là dedans pim
il ya des trucs qui reste comme depuis
j'ai 17 ans je fais des athlètes noirs
pin vabre qui je suis mais couleur
préférée
j'en suis
comme les couleurs que j'aime j'ai une
obsession de couleur fait aucun doute
c'est l'or mais mais en fait je suis
comme très obstiné à ce niveau là donc
ils des trucs qui reviennent la hotline
noir et tout ça mais comme sinon les
thèmes évolué genre même le style de
dessin aussi évolué je me sens pas comme
prise dans un dans le même truc je t'ai
pris il ya trois ans festive je me sens
je me donne le droit d'évoluer après
bataille qu'un jour les gens vont comme
cette année tu y as many je vais c'est
comme je le vois déjà là depuis quelques
années c'est sûr que je suis plus comme
l'artiste mais c'est drôle parce que
vous avez quand même dans une autre
vision parce que ça fait moins longtemps
tu sais que mais je le vois comme avance
déjà dès qu'il y avait un top-5 gens
illustres attendait comme tout est
toujours là numéro un genre comme c'est
celle là audio de chez nous c'est comme
dit ci paraît étrange mais c'était se
passe par longtemps puis maintenant
meilleur bien de plaies nouveau c'est
normal on est en passe puis plein de
nouveautés rempiler fait que justement
ces réflexions là mais j'en passe moine
qui serait pas déçu parce que j'ai mille
autres passions je sais pas là visuel
c'est vraiment pas aussi chez très
nettement comme 11 et tantôt la musique
c'est comme plus ma passion que l'on
fait maintenant que toucher jour au
lendemain un pick up l'art visuel ça
marchait plus un motard âgé trou ouais
ouais
messenger mais quand même
oui à temps j'enlève la musique en c'est
sûr que j'aimerais créer de la musique a
éventuellement de cépie je vois comme
l'art visuel puis le fait que ça prend
comme tellement de place dans ma vie
comme une comme ça q book trop tard pour
que je puisse vraiment m'acharner accord
pour commencer à écrire puis c'est
peut-être comme neil un instrument ou
vraiment commencé à explorer des trucs
je me suis jamais vraiment donné le
droit parce que l'or c'est ma seconde
l'art visuel maison de confort ces trucs
que je peux faire plus facilement mais
ça aussi c'est dangereux c'est trop
longtemps dans sa zone de confort moi
aussi ça commençait à me tracasser
vraiment l'année dernière que cette
année je me suis promis que j'avais
juste faire des trucs lmd stabiliser
puis que je parce que je voyais que je
stanier puis je me sentais mou rêve
chanter comme je me sentais moins
challenge et puis même si c'est de plus
en plus des nice contre eux puis découle
compagnie mouton ou des couleurs 6 avec
qui collaborer mais je me sentais comme
le défi était aussi grandjean le défi je
capable de ça c'est pas parce que c'est
un truc plus cool une plus grande
compagnie que mon site et plus et la
réaliser et et c'est comme ça je sais
comment le faire exister dangereux aussi
une balance comment je considère que
c'est dangereux fait que j'ai commencéà
comme explorer d'autres dotations que
j'ai pied fait preuve n'est pas question
comme je verrai juste comme une excuse
de me lancer dans une autre c'est la
musique oui mais aussi comme j'aimerais
vraiment commencer j'aimerais ça m'a
acheté quelque chose à l'histoire de la
ville puis vraiment commencé à passer
plus de temps nature qui a cultivé des
trucs en grande comore comme c'est leur
sculpture puis les plans que les plantes
médicinales pigeon observe par les
champignons fixe aussi juliette est
montré dans plein de deux espaces
différents que j'ai envie de faire pipi
sinon comme honnêtement je me verrais
bien mais recyclé dans un travail plus
comme humain gens de type travail social
s'effectue comme pas de manque
il ya pas de manquer ce niveau là mais
c'est sûr que si tu me disais que je
pouvais plus m'exprimer art
artistiquement puis je pouvais plus
comme sortir ce que j'ai une tête de
manière comme parce que c'est une
thérapie
moi honnêtement c'est une thérapie pour
moi
puis si tu ne faisais que le jeu
pourrait plus façonne d'aucune façon
sans lui ça soit la danse les chiens
pour moi une expression ouais ouais un
moyen d'expression mais je vois leurs
visuels comme un outil bien justement je
vois comme la musique comme un os toutes
ses pieds le champ comme un autre c'est
la danse qui aurait pas de danse mais
c'est sûr je veux bien mais si des
médiums et des médiums différents mais
qui permet aussi une naissance qui est
finalement là même le qui t'intéresse
pas quelque chose qu est ce qui coûte
séquences cultes comme néo comme une
façon de de t'exprimer donc comme ces
musiciens sont attendus repose in town
consolider ce qu'ils disent qu'ils à
pogny condamné qui sauve qui assistait
hier une période de transition comme
qu'il faudrait je devienne vraiment
bonne j'ai vu des vidéos toits de zinc
il rappelé ce salon internet
j'ai fouillé moi je vais mener les
recherches n'avaient non mais là la vie
notre job c'est vrai le hamas ariary
mais c'est clairement un truc j'ai voulu
faire car cachés qui l'amusé je
m'alignais pas pour sa part de la
musique c'est comme le focus de ma vie
qui je chantais tout le temps je pensais
que j'allais faire ce pied la vie est
comme pris un autre chemin méchas encore
que faisait vraiment je pense pour de
vrai que c'était ça ma vraie vocation
toulouse puis je pense pas que tu aies
ça enlève rien à ce que je fais le
clairement je le fais avec autant de
deux commissions et dans mon milieu de
quelque chose de plus viscéral
quand je change ou de 15 j'entends même
d'amis de la marque connexion à la
musique est beaucoup plus forte que ma
connexion alors visuel c'est pas du
genre comme à pleurer d'avoir picasso le
genre très ému par leurs visuels ça
m'affecte mai
ma connexion avec la musique comme
puisse la musique a sauvé ma vie j'en
millions de fois que je peux pas dire ça
de leur visionnaire ouais j'ai tellement
l'impression que tu payes reste ce genre
doit clairement tout à titre de madame
anne d'un intérêt pour la vie du député
petit tête-à-tête chambre allemand mais
apparemment tout le temps pour le fun
temps +17 une grande culture du hip hop
et de la musique en général c'est sûr
des foules d'abondants milieu genre
début mai que tu préfères débit toujours
tant qu'honnête 25 mai matin prêt à
faire une taxe non mais parce que
gigantesques monstres mais en fait c'est
sow qui me fait chi wah système ans et
que je pense à changeant la pression là
où j'allais aussi
non mais ce contrat comme sap une joke
si frêle vieillard qui me revient comme
friendly comme you seen and job dans un
freestyle à toronto blahblah les en
revanche comme beau jeu comme si ce cas
le sahara d'abord je tenais georges
d'orques un tel buzz rabardel coptes au
caire comme agathe show genre comme
vigan comme freddy comme les séquences
comme il ya du monde georges marchais
oden la première soirée qu on s'est
revus par chacun d'eux puis comme 2012
jean ces ententes
mais quand c'est comme revue rsa mais
pour que ça avance que bref quand on
était comme j'étais sur un rail parce
que je n'ai de composer une tonne du rap
de nerfs avec moi j'aime jean michel
schaeffer triste vraiment triste pour
mon ami travaille dans un studio au
ciseau apollo qui est
il était juriste du pop s'est produit au
fait qu'ils étaient huit ans le comme
sajoo qui convient tant le contenu du
rhum savenès finalement on a quand même
bizarre homme puis on a fait un jeu
moche en mode action phare cover de noël
gens on trouve la toune enfin communier
au juste pour comme repeat faire du bien
tout me suis jamais fait ça mais j'étais
vraiment au quesne convaincu comme enfin
commune elle commença tchéquie toutounet
n'a aucun conseiller le monde punaises
qui font des cover qui te fait quoi puis
il ya d abord nice de rap comme gucci
mane a fait un bond daniel entier comme
les artistes qu'on n'aime pas la
première escapade à petit les
intéressent pour tous les jours festifs
mais dans le fond on voit des puits au
final et comme les phoques et des gens
comme faisant une demande si on a pas
puisque le nom de quoi tu parles jamais
compositeur
finalement il est comme on sacralise
comme fait juste le faire puis j'ai
juste comme il me donnait un pas de
papiers puis comme écrit un rab janquin
fait les arts island comme si tu es
sable je me mettais mon impression passe
comme si à dix ans sûr que j'allais face
mais j'ai jamais pratiqué jamais fait ça
mais j'ai 31 ans puis je n'ai encore pas
fait confiance je vous ai fait que c'est
comme si toutes ces années le comme j'ai
pas eu des gains plus grands teams plus
loin sur la ligne du temps c'est comme
la pression mais ce que je me mets gens
et non non non non ce genre d'avariés
canon sarkozy c'est sa nièce comme on
tend le fait qu'ils n'avaient pas de
papiers
j'ai juste c'est crazy jean j'ai jamais
vu vix comme ces gens épiphanie pauvres
est pour moi ces gens j'ai juste
commencé à écrire comme si au lendemain
je te jure mais j'ai jamais fait ce
genre pour quelqu'un qui écrit dans son
journal ne s'est pas un matin
comme un fan carnaval terrifiant mais je
fais pas sauf et j'ai même pas
l'habitude comme des crises mâchant pas
là dessus c'est pas un truc que je
pratique mais comme ces sorties +8 et
couché sur ce faux fichier commun qu'ils
utilisaient lovers puis cyrielle ans à
la piste est comme dans sexy hriech avec
qui c'est bon tu sais si tu es caen -
dun qui faisaient leur travail mais
j'écris j'écris le social a mis notre
iphone littéralement comme v buzz
commence à zéro talent jeunesse pij
comprenez poster comme je t'ai posséder
le voir juste rue ou hold up mais c'est
seul plan c'est joe rios ont largement
mis en échec comme de faire face à son
passé fait qu'on le pot fait planter des
jours muse mois de décembre c'était
comme keyyo foule a sorti mes jambes
comme dix jours mais sur le fond il
faudrait que la peau fils parce que les
deux premiers jours c'était vraiment
naïf mais leur rêve quand tu es
tellement vulgaire ou non mais ce serait
pour vous seriez pas fia comme en tant
que femme on serait juste prix c'est
l'histoire de gens me ce club que je
m'éclate comme la femme ce que sinon hop
le son mari commis sans vaut encore j'en
serais aussi le coup toutes les beaux
jours de l'année mais la veille de noël
bas les pattes un accord avec thébaux et
marque
enfin les enfin toutes les familles
comme année la joie de chacun mais
réglée comme en tabarnak déjà si c'est
comme absent parce qu'il faut qu'elle le
tout la quinzaine mais comme en corner
pin règle est acquise puis à vire ce top
c'est comme le gros partenaire bonheur
pour d'un côté ja à four comme toutes
les limites elle s'est complètement ce
genre en mode vengeance mais là si la
chance est que ya tout un regard aussi
devrait sur cet homme
amuse toi j'en laisse ou à devrait comme
fois qu'elle prend d'un béret tourniquet
la jouer sexy sushi bar à bulles mais la
vie cet homme est tellement fils parce
qu'ils pensent au world tour payés comme
des revenants wable à l'oeil au à vire
ce top mais si c'est bon ça c'est juste
que j'ai honnêtement si tellement
faisceau naturellement ça me terrifie de
caumont halte à écouter aussi chic
ah ouais c'est honnêtement quand je fais
des trucs il est toujours seul en tout
les trucs que j'ai fait un peu comme
trop et puis s'il ment comme ça c'est
des trucs eu trop violent genre
complètement déchaîné ordre de vulgaires
à fond pied jeu comme chic on prend mais
ça donnera quoi le nom mais c'est juste
parce que c'est fait pisser c'est comme
très humoristique c'est pas sérieux le
sport comme de facto c'est comme ce
juste vraiment drôle à quel point sa vie
extrêmes
aujourd'hui aux coûts et le fait que
jean une journée par année elle est
séparée elle même qui a à vivre ce temps
puis je suis vraiment drôle ça serait
comme pas de rôle serait possible
hu et bien écrit mais on en a parlé
récemment
parce que le cooking avait-il été conçu
c'est écrit le truc il faisait le son
pour un défilé de mode que je viens de
faire
puis on a reparlé s'asseoir le pied
jetez un coup d'oeil aux longs nez comme
c'est [ __ ] quand même plus sexy fait
je sais pas qu'est ce qui m'a pris je
n'ai jamais eu cette confiance là mais
tout de suite après avril à thoune j'ai
comme lui livre ça tous les matins je
connaissais et qui est comme ce texte
rend pas plus tu es comme en mode on a
kiffé llopis et dompter vicente mais on
sait que ça m'enlève de la pression
juste comme voici l'histoire des mets 4
voici mon single qui y est tellement
d'importance pour moi exactement c'est
comme acquise une fois qu'ils nous
donnent l impression sérieux on y est
dans neuf puis gelé aujourd'hui par là
pas mal de monde puis c'est 56 et vince
haïti qui met you be des balades en tout
le monde était comme un casier
quand j'ai parlé c'est joe kevin smith
jason akira ce matin d'honneur comme
pendant une semaine je m'inquiète c'est
comme ça ta vie comme kim et ça fait
genre deux ans que tu n'y as quand des
choses aux gens que tu puisses tabac
blair comme arrêt de niaiseries pis faut
qu'il vienne gens parce qu'à mon âge on
se prend pour son rhume toupie à donner
qu'à ce moment-là il y déjà yocum juste
pourquoi j'ai jamais vu ce sens mais
comme you s'entraîne fort début d'année
déjà rapidement fait au début en intro
la norme et non mais c'est parce que la
toune je lis composé sur un beat de
neige à youtube
si je le vis des gens agressifs trappe
comme excellent
biden a et non merci bonjour le ring au
filet mais en fait parce que en fait non
attention ce thème icloud parce que
c'est un beat de ça une toune m et viry
by ap la cgc comme la tourner comme dans
tintin tintin tintin mais vraiment tu
feras tu as bossé comme des secours
facebook est là mais pauvre il était
calé depuis qu'on a parlé le tellement
de sauter par l'union cela si je le fait
notre job sharing
oui oui le père la haine de jean le père
n'est qu'en full pitt outils comme des
deux rappeurs ça sent un peu comme les
doudous comme le dit qui déjà huit
minutes avec même personnage complément
des mesures et des explosions des
cheveux comme si les trucs un peu trash
la dation le genre tâche et s'apprend se
permettre
en fait si c'est trop qu'elle internet
des agences afrique jean louis sofres
montre à la défense
ce faudrait comme trouver des
personnages pour traiter l'élue times
les renne au nez rouge mais c'est juste
comme un doux c'est honnêtement j'ai
comme envie de faire ce projet le métro
paris mais une chose c'est que c'est ça
la musique c'est comme si fortement leur
visuel je me suis jamais mis autant de
pression mais la musique est étrangement
j'ai tellement de respect pour la
musique ça semble tellement forte que je
prends pas au sérieux il faut que je
venais pas faire même si ça commence
souvent cependant pas trop sérieux mais
oui comme j'imagine le podcast c'est au
début comme une pression folle injuste
comme à qui on n'a que l'amour on fait
du mieux qu'on peut qu'ils ont fait ce
comme pour le fun parce qu'on ne
antilles on avait dix villes n'ont pas
encore candidat elles sont là non mais
tu sais comme moi qui ont fait ce puits
le jeu et ça marche pays
c'est le fun on aime se dit tranquille
mais c'est comme ça devienne quoi de
plus sérieux m mais au regard des
enfants comme ce truc le des genres
c'est pour le fun ses pieds sur le plan
pas on le fait parce que ça nous fait
bien
merci beaucoup
la fin est vraiment le dessus
que ce soit pour toi de méthodes non
mais qui s'en vient il ya des projets
dont je ne peux pas parler mais qui sont
vraiment dresser vraiment important pour
moi mais bientôt seront dévoilés sinon
une collection de vêtements
[Musique]
qui a pour thème la santé mentale est
principalement l'anxiété dieu et donc ça
ça va sortir cet automne et donc comme
un pop up shop sur mon avenir avec ce
thème qui les charrient chars pour tout
ça pour moi et puis ça va dans la lignée
de faire des trucs avec drake ou bien
celles exerçant sur la future